[music playing]
Bladesmiths, welcome
back to the forge.
You've had five days
at your home forges
to work on your jumonji yaris.
Fuad, how did it go?
Oh, it went really well.
Everything went
according to plan.
I used a lot of two-part
components in my construction,
and I'm very happy with
the overall result.
Jacob, how did it go for you?
It went pretty good.
I ran into several
complications,
but overall I think
it went pretty well.
All right, gentlemen.
Now it's time to see how they
hold up in our weapons test.
Up first, the kill test.
Doug.
The yari, with its long
handle and multi-pronged spear,
makes it a trifecta of points
and edges, and a deadly weapon.
To see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your
yari and deliver
multiple slashes and
thrusts on this pig carcass.
Fuad, you're up first.
You ready?
Oh, I'm ready.
I see Fuad's yari
and I'm like, wow.
I feel really good going
into weapons testing.
I think if the yari
is used in the ways
that I've read about
how it was used,
I know that I'm just going to
mince that thing with my yari.
[music playing]
Oh.
Jesus.
All right, Fuad, let's
talk about your yari here.
We felt that it had
very good balance to it.
That on the initial slash right
here, it dug in into flesh,
then it hit the spine.
The transference of energy hit
a weak spot into your handle
over here, but it still
had a secondary cut
all the way through.
I would consider
your blade a kill.
Thank you.
It was-- mine-- mine was
beautiful, well made.
And some wood grain
just, you know.
Fuad, your weapon suffered
a catastrophic failure.
Now, that's bad, however, you're
not out of this competition
yet.
Jacob, your yari still must
perform in this kill test.
Let's see what happens.
Right now I'm
feeling nauseous.
My heart's pounding in my chest,
my hands are sweaty, and I'm--
just can't wait to see
how it actually goes down.
[music playing]
All right, Jacob, let's
talk about your yari.
In the initial swing, instead
of being able to cut cleanly
with this part, to cut
through, this got in the way
with the angle that it had.
But let's talk about
these particular blades.
They are sharp enough to
penetrate into the pig carcass.
The thrust is really devastating
and very deep into that.
Your handle construction--
it stayed true.
No issues at all.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
Thank you, sir.
My yari held up, and I'm just--
thank you, God.
Well, Fuad, the
blades of your yari
were beautifully constructed.
The overall weapon
was very elegant.
However, your shaft broke in our
first test and we cannot move
forward in this
competition because that is
a catastrophic weapon failure.
And I have to ask you to
please leave the forge.
I was really confident
going into the competition,
and I felt like my yari
was going to really perform
a lot better than Jacob's.
And it's just pure
irony all the way down.
Maybe that small
flaw in that wood
was put there to teach
me some kind of lesson
that I have to derive
from the cosmos somehow,
but right now it
feels pretty bad.
Jacob, you are the
Forged in Fire champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
[applause]